hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be having
a bit of a departure from our normal
format instead of me telling you about
something teaching a lesson with the
whiteboard I'm going to be asking some
questions of my grandmother this is
Doris she is my Mimi and she's going to
be telling us some of her memories
surrounding growing up in a world where
there was still polio so you've probably
heard of polio you probably know that it
can cause paralysis under that can be
lethal it's been eradicated in the
United States since 1979 and so and it's
also eradicated globally and all except
three countries its Pakistan Afghanistan
and Nigeria still have active polio and
so unless you live in one of those
places you probably don't remember or
never knew what it was like to grow up
with polio being a very real concern so
what we're going to be talking about
today is mine Amy's recollections about
polio so when did you first know that
polio was a disease you had to be
worried about oh well I think I was in
my teens from great we'd have media and
stuff like you do nowadays to tell us
all those things so it's kind of slowly
getting the message but once you knew
that polio was a concern and you were in
your your teens or early 20s was it
something that you were scared of yes
yes yes I was you have a story about
going ice skating where you had some
concerns about polio can you tell us
that well soon as I stood up and fell
down on the lake I'm on my ankle bad
sprain so I had to I went home for it to
get my shoe off my foot was swollen my
mom took me to the doctor the next day
he wrapped it up said it was really a
bad spring and I think I kept that on
maybe ten days and I went back when he
took it off my foot was green and purple
and yelling black
and I thought polio and what did your
mama say so that's just bruises from
being wreck so you had you had your foot
all wrapped up so it was a little
bruised and discolored but you knew that
polio causes paralysis and so when you
thought there was something wrong with
your foot you thought maybe it was polio
yes luckily it was not but he did know
some a couple of other people who had
who contracted polio and then had
mobility issues later on or a young girl
well she's about your mom's age that has
she has real short legs she has to wear
crutches she uses crutches
we're sorry was a little big thing on
crutches and she still crutches on to
this day and the friend of your pet
pause I don't know how he contacted it
but he did it get me didn't have it and
he wanted to go hunting one time with
fellow the boys so okay sure papaw and
his friends carried him on their back to
the hunting field so he could usually
because of the polio this man had to use
crutches and used crutches in order for
him to go hunting with his friends which
included my grandfather but this has
been in like the 50s maybe your pet
graduate been late forties make 40 yeah
so so his friends would have to actually
carry him on their backs through the
wood you know because he couldn't use
his crutches right here than what area
because it was so overgrown yeah yes so
in order for him to participate and sort
of this normal activity he had to
actually be carried by his friends
because into this day then both of these
people still wear crutches you have to
use crutches to get around they do
manage I've seen him in his kitchen and
he says crutch under each arm or when
he's out in a way he has a motorized
wheelchair that his company gave him
when he retired so that's that's good
yeah I know he can get around with that
that's good
do you remember being vaccinated for
polio what not vaccinated
we had oral
it's an oral vaccine okay alright so
today you know two two vaccines right
one developed by you told me Jill does
so she remembers the name Jonas Salk the
other by Sabin yeah
and one is sort of an injectable vaccine
with an inactivated virus and the other
is a weakened virus and that's the oral
drops and you told me what it looks like
we had they put them in these little
little containers like they put medicine
in in nursing homes and a little deal
like that and they give you just drink
it better swallow I think you maybe get
it take three of those at different
intervals that's still true today if I'm
if a baby follows the the normally
recommended CDC vaccine schedule they
get a couple of polio vaccines for the
age of one and then I think there's a
booster around age trying to remember
maybe around age four or five so for
example my daughter has had two of those
three polio shots which means that she's
over 90% protected against polio but
still needs that final booster in a
couple of years to make sure that she's
fully protected when did you have the
the oral vaccination must have been in
that 1958 that's I was expecting your
mama so my mother was born in 59 you
know I know the polio vaccine has been
around since I think it started in 55
they they start I don't remember where
they started giving to everybody I just
know that we all went to the health
center on Sunday and got this done for I
forget it like say three different times
and because they could get more people
that way so we always we did a little
Sunday yeah okay and that helped
yes it did um because since then you
haven't known anybody else to get polio
no I haven't that's really good
in fact I've almost forgotten to bed
till I say those two people mm-hmm
we're very lucky that we don't have to
be concerned with polio the way people
did in your generation okay well I guess
that is it for today Thank You Mimi for
telling us you're the dirtiest and I
guess we'll see you guys next time if
you're interested I have another
interview with my Mimi where she told us
about her recollections regarding
hookworm so if you're understood and
what she has to say about that then you
can check out that video and thanks for
watching I will see you next time bye